éit mariée nouvelle mariée et j'avais
mon beaufrère et ma belle sœur ils était
venu puis comme il y avait pas assez de
chambre on avait mis un Mata ma
belle-mère elle avait mis un Mata par
terre pour qu'il couche et puis j'ai
trouvé un petit ballon alors je dis oh
ma mère regardez j'ai trouvé un petit
ballon je vais le gonfier on va le
mettre pour Bernadette comme ça elle me
dit mais Fernande vous savez pas ce que
c'est ah ben je dis non c'est un petit
ballon que j'ai trouvé dans le lit de
par terre B et c'était une compote
anglaise compot compote une compote
ouais c une compote une compote anglaise
pas une capote VO
elle me dit
mais non tu crois que maintenant il
savent les jeunes ah mais mamie il y a
des cours à l'école où on t'explique
tout même sans parler de l'école même
les parents ils te le disent alors bien
sûr qu'il y a des familles dans
lesquelles ça on n parle pas mais mais à
l'école on apprend pour autant chez moi
non